one of the things that we've discovered
in the science is that children who
already have moral intuitions from the
time they're extremely young
so even 14 month olds will go out of
their way to try to help someone else
who's in trouble and there's even some
evidence that this is true for babies
for infants so the old picture that we
had about moral development was that
children started out being these amoral
egocentric creatures and then they had
to be socialized into being moral or
caring about other people and that view
is sort of exactly the opposite of the
view that we have now there was a column
in the New York Times that said oh you
know someone like like Donald Trump is
like a two-year-old and I was extremely
irritated thought about writing a letter
to say that's a terrible insult to
two-year-olds two-year-olds are not
narcissistic and egocentric and only
concerned with they're only concerned
with their own their own happiness
they're they have the potential for
caring about other people taking care of
them it's something that happens between
being - and being grown-up that makes
the narcissists and the IGAs egotist of
the world develop that's a that's a
grown-up condition not a condition of a
two-year-old and as a parent the the
challenge is to try to give children
information and encouragement for those
natural tendencies towards altruism no
it has to be said that we have a lot of
evidence that that natural tendency
towards altruism towards helping for
others being empathic to others caring
for others seems to go hand-in-hand with
a tendency to split people up into an
in-group the people that we're empathic
for and take care of and then an
out-group the others and the others are
the ones that we don't have to take care
of and those two things from an
evolutionary perspective even from
physiological neuroscience perspective
seem to go hand-in-hand so the challenge
for a parent is to say give give
children a sense of encouraging that
sense of belonging and caring about
other people without also having a sense
that you only do that for your group
you cannot care about the other group
you